what's the other thing we know about
this population and it's a specific
phase of Life remember age is more than
a chronological fact
what else do we know about this
population 18-24
they are stupid
that is why we put them in dormitories
and they have a resident assistant
they make really bad decisions
all right people we are live from the
swamp that's right I am in Washington DC
I'm still a Dave Rubin this is still the
Reuben report it is November 14th Monday
November 14th
2022 we are live streaming as always on
Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV subscribe if
you have not and yes we got on a plane I
put the team on a plane from the free
state of Florida this morning and we we
actually just arrived last two hours or
so here in DC and we are doing a couple
days worth of shows so that we're
obviously at a special time today 3 P.M
but tomorrow and Wednesday we'll be back
to our normal 11 A.M time slot and we're
going to be doing some live shows I've
got a couple meetings we're going to be
doing interviews which are still
materializing on the fly at the moment
but I know we have Senator Ted Cruz and
Senator Rand Paul we've got congressman
Aaron Donald I think we might have
Marcia Blackburn a couple other people I
think are on the way oh Jim Jordan I'm
going to be sitting down with him a
little bit later today Congressman Jim
Jordan Senator Josh Hawley we got we got
basically like an A-list All-Star team
of people to talk about what just
happened right I mean everyone is still
trying to make sense of what happened
last week clearly it wasn't the Red Wave
does look like the Republicans will at
least get Congress although that's a
little bit
up in the air still and speaking of up
in the air we still don't even have
results from Arizona which is which is
Banana Republic type stuff like
unacceptable no matter which way it goes
at this point
um it's just unacceptable to not have
results really within the day of the
election and we're gonna have to deal
with all that uh but the theme of the
show today really is let's make some
sense of this thing and what do we do
going forward and you know should we
have followed polls or not followed
polls who got some stuff right who got
some stuff wrong and and what is the
future of let's say the as I always say
the sort of broad conservative movement
because it's thriving in some places
right it is freaking thriving in Florida
right it's doing really well in Texas
and Tennessee and South Dakota and Iowa
there are places where this is working
but there are places that seemingly want
to go just Bluer and Bluer and Bluer so
we're going to get to all that one
little just side note that I I saw on
the way here as we were walking over and
I was looking at the Twitter uh first oh
I should tell you also there's no people
in DC I don't know where everyone is I
there are just it's like a goat complete
Ghost Town actually Daphne and I were
walking over to the studio and uh we
didn't see anybody and then finally we
were walking under a bridge and there
was this massive like homeless
encampment or under the bridge so we
were kind of like ah is there another
way to go around but we were like we got
to get there we're gonna walk by the
cabinet this guy pops out of a tent and
like we kind of jumped a little bit
because it looked like he was like
coming right at us and he's like no no
dude I don't want your money I just want
your jacket
he just wanted my jacket can't have the
jacket I have work to do uh anyway we
are here in DC the the split between the
red and the blue is very very obvious
and we are in the swap trying to make
some sense of it oh and also I will be
on uh Tim pools Tim cast tonight at uh
at 8 p.m okay oh and the one thing I
want to tell you was I saw something
right before which was that New York in
the last couple years has lost around
550
000 people you take the last few years
of covet and everything else Kathy
hochel
only won the election overly zeldon who
she was supposed to crush I really did
think Lee had a chance he made it very
close New York flipped a bunch of blue
congressional seats red so zeldon at the
top of the ticket did a heck of a job I
think he's got a bright future
um but he only lost to her by about 350
000 votes so if you factor in the amount
of people that fled
more people fled than the margin of
error the margin of loss for Lee zeldon
so it tells you how the the red and the
blue perhaps are just going to get
further and further apart that might be
okay anyway we got a whole bunch to talk
about uh let's start with I can't
believe it I don't mention that often
Saturday Night Live which used to be a
comedy show the not ready for Prime Time
Players used to be a comedy show on NBC
for many years it's been on for about I
don't know maybe 50 years at this point
used to have some great All-Star
comedians
um anyway Dave Chappelle was the host
this week you guys know Dave Chappelle
has been fighting the woke he's actually
a politically incorrect comic I don't
agree with everything the guy says but
he did an interesting monologue where he
tried to explain to a New York City
largely liberal crowd on a show where
many of the writers boycott the show
because he was going to be the host he
tried to explain what Trump was all
about it was really interesting this is
about a minute and a half it's a couple
parts that are clipped together
and I'm watching the news now they're
declaring the end of the Trump era now
okay I can see how in New York you might
believe this is the end of his era a lot
of you don't understand why Trump was so
popular but I I get it because I hear it
every day
it's very loved
and the reason he's left is because
people in Ohio have never seen somebody
like him that first debate I've never
seen anything like it I've never seen a
white male billionaire screaming at the
top of his lungs this whole system is
rigged he said and across the stage was
white woman Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama sitting over there looking at him
like no it's not I said now wait a
minute bro it's what he said
and the moderator said well Mr Trump
if in fact the system is rigged as you
suggest
will it be your evidence
you remember what he said bro
he said
I know the system is rigged
because I use it I said God
isn't that true and then Hillary Clinton
she's watching the taxes she said this
man doesn't pay his taxes he shot right
back that makes me smart
everything
and then he said
if you want me to pay my taxes then
change the tax code
but I know you won't because your
friends and your donors enjoy the same
tax breaks that I do
and with that my friends a star was born
okay so Chappelle goes on and on and
we're as I said we're just showing you a
small portion of it there's some
interesting stuff there first at a later
point he says that I'm I think he says
I'm a Democrat and I'm still a Democrat
now it's interesting I don't know what
makes someone who is anti-woke a
Democrat at this point but okay he he
says he's a Democrat I know a lot of you
are watching on uh well Chappelle you're
you're just late to the party you're
making these jokes now but we saw it
then back in 2015 when he was running
against Hillary and he was talking about
all of that stuff and pulling that
curtain back we saw it while the entire
machine called Trump a racist and a
bigot and all of that so yes he's he's
late to the party but he is saying the
truth now so it is worth giving him
credit for again I don't know what would
lead someone like that that gets it if
he gets it and he gets how the system is
rigged I don't know how you could then
be with the party that is far more
involved with the rigging which is the
Democrats uh but so be it he does have a
strange way of racializing everything
like when he makes a point of saying
that Donald Trump was a white man and
Hillary Clinton's a white woman like I I
don't need any of that stuff it just it
just doesn't really matter but I do
think it is interesting that it is sort
of bursting into the mainstream and
there is nothing more mainstream and
sort of bland than Saturday Night Live
the idea that Trump was on to something
over these past couple years so why is
it worth even mentioning any of this and
talking about Trump just a few days
after the election and it's very unclear
to me at least whether Trump's
endorsements actually helped or hurt
people like you could argue I suppose
that he did help he was in Ohio the day
before the election JD Vance who was his
guy who was not a trump supporter back
in 2016. he did win so that's good Trump
was also in Michigan but Tudor Dixon
lost there's many examples of this Dr Oz
big Trump guy he lost so it's a little
hard to say what effect Trump actually
had on the election he always wants to
take credit for all the good parts and
not you know be included when it comes
to the bad stuff but in any event I'm
talking about all this because they are
saying it's out there they're saying it
people uh that Donald Trump is going to
announce tomorrow night that's what
people are saying Tuesday night this
week that Donald Trump is going to
announce that he is running for
president uh in 2024 and this is this
has got everybody talking I don't even
know if it's going to happen it's like I
sort of felt and I mentioned this last
week like after the election and trying
to make some sense of it like I think
everybody kind of needed a little bit of
a break but there are new fights to be
had right now there really are like the
Republicans have to figure out which way
do they want to go do they want to go
the Trump route is there a DeSantis root
is can those things be combined is it
the old route that had nothing to do
with either one of those guys and the
Democrats are they more emboldened now
right they simply no matter what happens
with Arizona the Democrats did not get
crushed in an off-year election that's
rare so now they're talking about
bringing Biden back there's just like a
lot of stuff right now and I was doing
cardio yesterday flipping through the
YouTube and Jordan Peterson was on Piers
Morgan's show and Piers asked Jordan to
give an assessment of Donald Trump and I
think this is worth watching I thought
it was very fair Donald Trump what is he
is he a narcissist a sociopath a
psychopath all of those things none of
them
I don't think that he's a psychopath
um because he's been successful in
repeated Enterprises over long periods
of time and he has a variety of people
who are remain intensely loyal to him
it's very easy to demonize someone that
you don't approve of let's say and
certainly Trump has been subject I would
say to more demonization than any
political leader in the west that I can
remember in my entire lifetime including
Richard Nixon and so that's also set him
back on his heels and made him somewhat
embattled in defensive which I don't
think did any great things for
for his personality in some real sense
the good doctor a very few analyze
things better than him let me just
reiterate a couple of things so he said
that Donald Trump is not a psychopath
right you watch mainstream media the
guy's a psychopath he's Hitler too blah
blah blah that he said he's been
successful there's no doubt that Trump
has been successful over long periods of
time in many different businesses he's
had many businesses fail too but he's
still standing the Trump name means
something right that's true he has
loyalty especially with the base
obviously uh and then I what he said
there at the end that he's been more
demonized than anyone and that that
could then have an effect on Trump's uh
sort of attitude and behavior I thought
was very interesting so they continued
to talk about this and then Piers Morgan
brought up if there was a better
alternative than Donald Trump and now
you'll see why I'm connecting all of
this to the post-election situation that
we're in would you like him to run again
would it be good for America do you
think
no I I don't think it would be good for
America would it be good for him to run
that's a diff that's a difficult
question because it might be that it
would be good for America to have
whether or not Donald Trump should be
president sorted out in the public
sphere debated intensely and subject to
an election so it might be very
interesting to see him put himself
forward on the Republican ticket if I
had my druthers
um and I say this I hope with due care I
would rather see someone like DeSantis
step forward who shares some of that
forthright
strength let's say that characterizes
Trump at his best but seems to be a more
uh cautious administrator and a less
divisive figure I think that would be
better
man I can't believe I do it with the guy
he's that good I still hear him now and
I think man if I could just explain
things the way he does I mean there's
there's a beauty to the way he describes
these things first off the way he
cautions things right like maybe the
battle should happen right like as
opposed to just indicting Trump pushing
Trump off into the corner ignoring the
base all of those things demonizing half
the country maybe the guys should run so
that the battle could be had out in the
open and people could see what the ideas
are see people could really see what the
tactics are he's saying maybe that would
be best but then he is saying that there
is another guy who has seemingly much of
the upside of trump on the policies and
the ideas and all of that and doesn't
have the downside is more disciplined is
more competent Etc so obviously that is
Ron DeSantis and Ron DeSantis right now
is feeling pretty great because if there
was one winner well I don't want to say
there was one winner there were millions
of winners because there's millions of
Floridians uh but there was one Winning
State
in my opinion uh last Tuesday and that
was Florida the guy not only won by 20
percent but he flipped districts like
Miami-Dade red that should not that no
one thought could ever go red uh he won
his last election in 2018 by about 30
000 votes against the guy named Andrew
Gilliam who was propped up by the
machine who turned out to be a meth
addict he was arrested out of meth orgy
like a year and a half ago DeSantis has
been an absolute All-Star you guys know
my feelings about DeSantis and what he
has done here I moved myself and my
family and several companies to Florida
and everything is flourishing I was
asked about DeSantis in Florida on Fox
uh two days ago give us a sense because
you're a newbie to Florida about how
people there are reacting to this
outcome
oh man it's off the charts I was
actually broadcasting that night about
100 feet away from the stage the energy
in that room was was unbelievable but
really what's happening here in Florida
with this 20-point win is that people
have just said enough of the woke stuff
enough of you you know encroaching on
our children and taking more of our tax
dollars and everything else how about
competent governance and that is what we
have done here at every single level
there is such incredible energy in this
state right now they're building houses
everywhere they're redoing roads uh you
know people obviously don't have state
income tax there is a feeling that our
education system will work better
because we're pushing the woke stuff out
DeSantis is basically doing exactly what
everyone asks politicians to do give us
the room to live our lives as we see fit
and then pick those those brief moments
where the government has to do something
he's doing it brilliantly well and I
think that was the best speech he has
ever given he's he's stepping into the
moment and that's why he's getting so
many attacks by the way at the moment
because people are realizing this this
is the real deal
okay so let me address a couple things
here so everyone in the media the last
couple of days is there that you can
feel it you can feel it and you can see
it and you certainly can hear it they
are salvating they are chomping at the
bit for this Trump desant this fight
right because if you are part of the
establishment if you're a Democrat if
you're a big Tech and your corporate
press what would you love to happen you
would love for the two guys that are the
big two Republicans to trash each other
destroy each other make everything so
raw and so scorched and burned and
shriveled and with nothing left that
whoever makes it to 22-24 is completely
hampered with a broken base and
everything else now I hope that that
does not happen that being said I do
agree with Jordan's sentiment that it
might be best if the fight happens
publicly again I don't know if DeSantis
wants to run I know the guy freaking
loves Florida but it does feel like it's
going in that direction a little bit and
and again I voted for Trump I like Trump
I like his children I think he's he was
a fantastic president uh but they all
have pluses and minuses right so like
one of Trump's major minuses I think
right now putting aside the the
personality stuff or indictments or
anything else one issue that he has for
sure is can Trump bring in new voters
right
and you got to look around people know
who Trump is so is Trump going to bring
in a whole bunch of new young voters
that are first-time voters
probably not maybe there could be some
but what does Trump do for sure if Trump
jumps in a certain amount of people who
just wouldn't vote probably will vote
against him right so maybe five million
people I don't know what the number is
right so he has a he may have already
hit his ceiling and we don't know how
low the floor can go so that's the the
main issue around him DeSantis to me
doesn't have many drawbacks they have to
have it out I would hope and this is if
anyone from the Trump campaign is
watching this or the DeSantis campaign
but this is more to the Trump people
it's like DeSantis has accomplished
everything he accomplished everything
here in Florida that you wanted to
accomplished for the nation he kept the
place open the economy is thriving
everything is working and chugging along
he fought the woke in the most efficient
possible way got it all out of our
schools our elections are safe he did
all of the things so Trump can't really
beat him on policy what Trump can do and
he absolutely can do this and he is
better than DeSantis at this and he's
probably better than anyone at it
because in essence he's in some ways
he's a he's a sort of working stand-up
comic Trump might be able to bring in
all of the dirt and make it really nasty
and make it not about policy but about a
bunch a whole bunch of other things so
that he could Ascend to the presidency
it is possible he could do that I would
hope he would not and I think he would
end up turning off a whole bunch of
people but we're going to really see
people go into their two camps and I was
thinking you know so much of what we see
in politics I often describe as kfabe
right
k-a-y-f-a-b-e Google it if you don't
know what it is it is the idea of
professional wrestling that we're we're
all watching professional wrestling we
know it's scripted yet we're having
honest human reactions to it and that's
in some ways what politics has become
it's this seemingly scripted thing
happening right in front of us well I
don't think the story in the script for
whoever is writing the script has to be
necessarily DeSantis destroys Trump or
Trump destroys DeSantis you know what
often would happen in the WWE back in
the day I can only give you references
from wrestling in around 1986 instead of
Jake the Snake Roberts and Hacksaw Jim
Duggan killing each other in the ring
sometimes they would team up and they'd
fight Andre the Giant and uh
Rafael Santana how is that you see you
see what I did there so maybe these guys
can team up I think anything's possible
we'll see what happens tomorrow but the
other piece that sits with all of this
is that because DeSantis has done things
so well in Florida uh they're they're
not really able to figure out what to
pin on him right and and that's what I
keep telling you guys Florida is the
blueprint it is the blueprint I'm very
proud and happy to live in the place
that is the blueprint and I know that
the people in the other control room
right now are are as well there is there
are a few people that live in Florida
that are not happy with the blueprint
one of them is the views Anna Navarro
who also is a CNN contributor of course
can you what a resume she's on The View
on CNN it's a lot anyway how did
DeSantis win it's not because he did
everything that Floridians asked no it's
not because that it's because he gave
him the system yeah I told you he was
going to win bigly but listen Rhonda
santis barely won in 2018. by 35 000
votes by the skin of his teeth against a
black Progressive little-known mayor
from Tallahassee Florida it didn't
yesterday he won by 20 percentage points
why because he gained the system because
he turned Florida into an unlevel
playing field they changed election laws
making it harder to vote by mail they
paraded a bunch of people black people
that they arrested for a voting fraud
and paraded them in front of national
media he created an election police
okay so Anna nonsense drivel and you're
literally basically the only person
saying that there were any Shenanigans
there's so many Shenanigans to really
talk about if you want to talk about
election irregularities and what's going
on in Arizona right now and you want to
talk about all of the early voting and
you want to talk about mail-in ballots
and you want to talk about drop boxes
and all of these things but nobody
nobody serious is saying that there was
anything wrong with the election here in
Florida so I'm not even going to give
her uh much of that but that he gained
the system it's just not right what he
did was he tightened the rules so that
everyone actually had to have an ID to
vote and most people did show up and
then by the way I mentioned it last week
when the hurricane hit he did loosen
some of the mail-in ballot stuff and
early stuff so that people would be able
to vote because they were dealing with
their own tragedies I mean houses that
were gone and all sorts of stuff he did
nothing racist they're not coming for
the gays here it's all just nonsense but
what does the mainstream media do of
course of course of course they have to
make you fear everything here's a tweet
from Fox I'm not even going to bother
showing you the MSNBC panel but this was
great MSNBC had a panel where
republican-controlled Texas and Florida
labeled Laboratories of autocracy by a
worried MSNBC panel so that is going to
be the new move that they on on
mainstream media they will constantly be
telling you that Florida is not free
it's an autocracy or it's fascistic or
that's what's happening in Texas and
some of these other red States and it's
like the proofs in the pudding you can
come here nobody's leaving Anna Navarro
lives in Miami Anna I know it's like it
says it in your Twitter bio I'm not
outing you you live in Miami that just
got flip read why don't you leave like
why don't you leave I think we know why
you don't you're enjoying the taxes and
you know it's actually pretty good here
let's continue though as long as I
mentioned the televised mental
institution of MSNBC here here's Joe
Scarborough explaining that it was
right-wing polling that was off on all
of this stuff what this is propaganda
why are you putting this and I really
think threw off a lot of people in the
media they followed those right-wing
garbage Falls
ah okay so we followed right wing
garbage polls now first off everybody
was expecting the Red Wave there were
almost no counter voices to that and
what did I tell you every time I I think
every time like sometimes I repeat
myself into into nauseum every time I
set a poll I would say I don't really
trust polls it's hard to gauge what's
going on here with polls but we talk
about right wing garbage polls we did
our best really really did our best to
go with a cross-section of polling so we
did Nate Silver's 538 it's a lefty like
he's an Obama guy that's not a
right-wing garbage poll Real Clear
Politics that's the one I usually use
that's a Centrist polling as you can
possibly get we used Pew and Emerson
these are the most reputable polling
operations outfits out there so the
question is were they all were they all
wildly wildly wrong did something really
go on with all of the these drop boxes
and the early voting and all of this
stuff like what the hell is going on in
Arizona or or is it really that a
certain amount this is what I said on
the show I think it was on Friday
like a certain amount of people no
matter how bad it gets no matter whether
the economy is crashing and we're in
this bizarre war in Ukraine and the
supply chain and oh you were locked in
your house and they forced you to inject
stuff and you got fired from a job they
just want more they just want more or
that the Republican brand the
alternative brand is just so bad and the
question is if that's true does that
have something to do with Trump that
these are all the things that we got to
kind of figure out now right we got to
figure these things out but the media
has been reacting to the uh to the
midterm elections and they trotted out
uh house Speaker Nancy Pelosi she's at
least house speaker for now we'll have a
better sense of that in a couple days to
talk about uh praying and elections or
something like that but again the races
are close and um
we just you know we don't pray for a
victory I I was grow up in a political
family don't pray for the victory but
you pray that God's will will be done
and on that Sunday that's what we pray
on this
what what
we don't pray for a victory
why can't Democrats speak
why has it become sort of the mainstream
Democrat position to be unable to
complete a sentence clearly this is Joe
Biden this is Nancy Pelosi with her
Dentures falling out this is John
fetterman
etc etc so she doesn't pray but she kind
of prays political family maybe she's
praying blah blah blah then she made a
very or she had a very bizarre response
when she was asked a question about her
husband Paul Pelosi who was assaulted
you may remember assaulted naked guy
Hammer unclear who got in how he got in
the glass was broken not inside the
house but outside like nobody knows
exactly what's going on but everybody
Hillary Clinton it was right wing uh you
know crazy people that did this in ilhan
Omar the rest and everyone uses it for
their own political purposes anyway
Pelosi was asked about Paul and uh well
try to make some sense of this asking
about your husband Paul how is he doing
well thank you for asking good morning
uh each day takes us closer to recovery
it's a long haul but he's doing well
comforted by the good wishes and
especially the prayers of so many people
throughout the country we thank them all
for that and again so many have said I'm
I'm going to be sure to vote because
this has gone too far
ah okay so something to do with voting
this has gone too far okay that's your
husband all right that's just fine then
she was asked whether Biden should run
again and now this is the interesting
one because everyone knows Biden is
breaking down he's at a climate Summit
right now in Egypt and his teleprompter
stuff was legendarily bad I didn't want
to show it today it was just like too
much I couldn't even deal with it but
the guy is breaking down it will be a
miracle if he gets to the end but
Nancy's all in you think President Biden
should run again
oh yes I do I mean President Biden has
been a great president for our country
he has accomplished so much
he's been a great president look at the
end of the day because we didn't get the
Red Wave a certain amount of people must
believe that right I have to I always
say we all have our blind spots we're
we're all sort of cordoned off in our
own little uh Echo Chambers to some
degree I do my best not to be in that
especially when I'm chatting with you
guys in the locals Community I know I'm
very proud of the fact that my audience
tries to get counter information and
find out some other things we don't get
all lost enough but we do have to accept
that a certain amount of people no
matter how ridiculous we think Biden is
no matter how mentally compromised he is
or how bad his policies are or or how
radical the the woke left has gone that
certain people again do want it that
there are certain States the idea that
someone could live in Michigan and
having been locked down and told not to
plant seeds in their yard and all of the
stuff that Gretchen Whitmer did and more
than 50 percent of the people voted for
her again we have to accept that these
are realities we may not like them to be
realities but this this EXP government
of the United States of America is
splitting to a degree and as you know
that is federalism and that is okay it
makes it sound like oh you want
secession and you want Civil War and all
of those things no I want the states to
operate fully independently and the and
the federal government to be neutered
enough to not bother the states and I'm
saying that here in DC where I'm pretty
sure they can take me out when I walk
outside but usually they don't hit the
guy they're trying to take out they hit
the other guy so uh not great for not
great for you guys uh anyway uh Biden uh
was asked if he is going to run again in
2024.
obviously a lot of attention on 2024 now
that the votes have been cast in the
midterms two-thirds of Americans in exit
polls say that they don't think you
should run for reelection what is your
message to them and how does that factor
into your final decision about whether
or not to run for re-election it doesn't
what's your message to them so those
two-thirds watch me
yeah we do watch you Joe we do and
from I think an objective situation
you're not doing a very good job but
again I get I fully do get it it's hard
to track because of polls that make no
sense and big text making us all crazy
and all that stuff I guess a certain
amount of people do watch you and go my
God Joe Biden knows what he's doing it
seems like he really is doing good and
it seems like they might think that
they're Democrats are doing good uh I
guess maybe because people aren't taught
basic math and basic logic anymore so
they see their all of their bank
accounts going down they see the value
of the dollar going down and they
somehow think that that's kind of good
here's our black lesbian press secretary
Karin Jean-Pierre explaining why
Republicans lost and uh yeah nonsense
the Republican candidates said their top
priority was undoing inflation reduction
act which would raise Crispin jogs which
would raise energy costs and also health
care costs and so they were very clear
on how they were going to lay out ways
that it would hurt the economy worsen
inflation
okay I don't even know where to begin
with this lady look the inflation
reduction Act was called the inflation
reduction act because you have to call
something that's not good you got to
give it a good name and what it was was
a giant spending bill that did not
reduce inflation but it said reduction
act so a lot of people think so the
Republicans though I'll give the devil
is deal with the Democrats the
Republicans obviously didn't communicate
a better alternative right they
obviously didn't because enough people
somehow didn't think that hey if we
could just get these people out of here
who are endlessly spending if we could
just maybe give the power to the other
guys and just see what happens enough
people just didn't want to do that so
what do you do what do you do well I
like finding Solutions right that's how
we always end this show we like to find
Solutions even when I'm here in DC not a
place of tremendous Solutions although I
do have to say the studio here is
fantastic and the people have all been
great
um it's not a place of solutions but I
believe in solution so what would
couples salute Solutions B well one
would be that we take back and crush the
institutions that have so manipulated us
so that so many of us are living in
different worlds because we believe
wildly wildly different things I thought
Marco Rubio my new my ongoing Senator uh
right here or right back home in Florida
uh had a great commentary on how
remarkable it is actually that
Republicans do win despite everything
but I think we also have to understand
something I mean literally every
everything in our society and culture is
aligned against Republicans it's America
where Republicans went anywhere every
virtually every major television and
media Outlet in America is against us
all the celebrities all the movie actors
I mean you name it it's just constant
the tech companies uh the list goes now
of major American corporations so it's
amazing that Republicans are even
competitive much less winning these
seats and look I think we're going to
win the house
all right that's worth reiterating now
first off it does look like Republicans
are going to win the house by a very
very slight majority but the broader
point there that all of the cultural
norms have been against us big Tech and
television and music and all of the
stuff movies all of it right uh and as
Andrew Breitbart said politics is
Downstream from culture so we have been
fighting this massive thing and and just
if you're paying any attention beyond
what I do on the show to what's going on
with Elon and Twitter he's exposing a
lot of the nonsense and he's firing
people left and right because we have
been manipulated in crazy ways so the
idea that as as Rubio says the idea that
Republicans are competitive that these
things are so close despite one side
having everything against it and not
doing all the vote trickery beforehand
as they do in Democrat States it's
actually pretty remarkable and that
should give you a lot of Hope actually
that there are more of us and there are
more freedom loving people and people
that are proud of the flag and proud to
be Americans and all that uh so okay so
we have to take back some of these
institutions these cultural and Tech
institutions but I would also say number
two we have to be a United I could say
party but I want to say movement because
it's not about a party right like I
happen to have registered as a
republican in Florida but I don't
consider myself I certainly don't
consider myself like a standard
Republican or even a standard
conservative but a movement a wide
movement of all sorts of freedom-loving
people who can argue about drivers
licenses at the libertarian end and can
argue about uh same-sex marriage or
whatever else but all agree that we want
to live in America we believe in
individual rights we believe the
founding is good that's what we must do
and then from a party perspective you
have to support good candidates Blake
Masters it does look like he's going to
lose I don't think he's officially
conceded yet but it does look it's a
damn shame because he's a good man he is
a he has a bright future in front of him
for sure but it does look like he's
going to lose in Arizona uh he was on TV
talking about how the Republican machine
didn't not help them enough at best just
incompetent but you know what else is
incompetent Tucker The Establishment
right the people who control the purse
strings Senate leadership fund Mitch
McConnell McConnell decided to spend
millions of dollars attacking a fellow
Republican in Alaska instead of helping
me defeat Senator Mark Kelly had he
chosen to spend money in Arizona this
race will be over we'd be celebrating a
senate majority right now
so look I don't like to think it's all
about money but a lot of it is about
money and we need an apparatus let's say
again broadly on the right it's not
about purely Republican or something but
an apparatus that is focused and
efficient and all of those things that
is using money well
um I don't think we have that at the
moment and I think more and more people
are realizing that after this election
um so wait sorry what's the next clip
we're
oh the thing froze up for just a sec
sorry
uh for number three though on my list of
how we're gonna fix this thing we need
measured and competent leaders who we
can trust right okay and here's where I
have to hit Trump on something because
Trump sent out a couple posts on Truth
social and it's like he could comment on
the election and say hey this is what
went wrong this is what went right these
are the ideas we stand for this is what
they stand for people didn't come around
that I would have like the way I would
have liked but instead he's going back
to some of his old stuff and I just
don't think this is the stuff we need
anymore here's a post on truth from
Trump he wrote young kin now he's
talking about Glenn young kin now that's
an interesting take sounds Chinese
doesn't it in Virginia couldn't have won
without me Trump wrote on Truth social
the social media platform he helped
found I endorsed him did a very big
Trump rally for him telephonically got
maggot a vote for him or he couldn't
have come close to winning but he knows
that and admits it besides having a hard
time with the Dems in Virginia India but
he'll get it done look I don't know what
is he trying to imply that somehow he's
Chinese or something young can like we
just don't need this no one in their
right mind Donald Trump anyone that is
an Associated Donald Trump again I voted
for you I like you we don't need these
games anymore if you're if you think
that Glenn Younkin is the enemy
if you think that Ron DeSantis is the
enemy then you gotta find the mirror
right like you got to look at yourself
and go what am I really trying to do
here am I trying to make this all about
me or am I trying to find the best
possible people to put in these jobs to
to lead to a country that is something
like the country I want to live in Glenn
young and basically is doing a great job
in Virginia and and the proof is in the
pudding Ron DeSantis is absolutely
crushing it in Florida and the people
see it so I don't think these tricks are
going to work Glenn youngin actually had
a nice response to to the Trump post
what's your reaction first of all I
didn't see it um
I have to be honest I've been busy all
morning
um listen I I you you all know me I Do I
Do Not Call people names I I really work
hard to bring people together and that's
what we're working on well that's what
I'm saying and and I just that's not the
way I roll and not the way I behave and
and I think again this is a moment for
us to come together
yeah that's kind of right like we can
lick our chops we can or lick our wounds
rather we can lick our wounds and go all
right well what's going on here what do
we have to do to be better and is it
better to throw out these bombs and
young Kim and what Ron Des sanctimonious
like this stuff or to lay out better
policies like what actually do people
want I think we're the mature group I
think we're the side that actually wants
Clarity and competency and we want
Leaders with spines who do the right
thing no matter the cost I was reminded
of this video this is from almost this
is a year and a half ago now almost two
years ago when Ron DeSantis decided to
lift the ban on nursing homes here in
Florida and and just listen to this in
case you forgot it they're not demanding
a medical miracle they're not uh having
unrealistic expectations they just would
like to be able to say goodbye or to hug
somebody so
it was you know
I think it's difficult
[Music]
um
to think that some of our actions may
have prevented
there's a way to do this right there's a
way to do this with humility and
humanity and again I'm not attacking
Trump over this I'm telling you dude you
got to be better at the moment if you
want people to come I'm seeing a lot of
people that are getting off that Trump
train a lot of people and again we don't
even know what the scientist wants to do
we genuinely do not know but I think
people have had it with the games like
Junkin doesn't owe you anything at this
point to say it just doesn't owe you
anything did you help them likely
probably maybe definitely but that's not
necessarily what this is all about and
if you're going to try to take out or
mock the guys that are doing the work
they're getting in there doing all the
stuff that you would want done
it's it's not I think it's going to be a
major problem but there is a winning
strategy
it is Florida it is competency it is
Clarity it is doing what's right and
it's showing people that if you stand up
and you fight the woke and you fight the
corporations and you fight the political
Machinery that people will back you
because they're looking for a leader
my job is to protect the education
opportunities and the jobs of the people
of my state and if doing so means I put
my own job in Jeopardy we'll let the
chips fall where they may leadership is
about standing up for other people
before you worry about your own hide
yeah it's as simple as that guys it's as
simple as that and that's the battle
that has to has to happen and to just
circle back to where we started with
Jordan Peterson talking about this maybe
it all has to happen out publicly right
if they both decide to run maybe it all
has to happen maybe that's the best
thing right like if Trump is either
indicted or doesn't run and it seems
like it's just handed to DeSantis maybe
DeSantis won't be refined enough when he
gets into a general election like we can
talk about all that kind of strategy
stuff and that's interesting stuff and I
like talking about all that stuff and
whatever but I don't think the strategy
of just I will make it personal and burn
it all down and Destroy Everything which
seems to be more in line with what Trump
might do if you're going after yanking
and DeSantis this way
um I don't think that's the future I
just don't think it's the future at
least it's not a future that I want to
be part of and it's certainly and again
I say this as someone that likes him
likes his kids voted for him and in
certain situations would vote for him
again obviously and would absolutely
vote for him before voting for a
Democrat so that's my thoughts on all of
that stick around for a old clothes guys
and it is me Monday over at the Reuben
report locals community and since I am
in the swamp today you can see what I
posted right there you'll never find a
more wretched Hive of scum and villainy
ironically I can't find any people out
on the streets here in DC but we'll keep
looking we will a couple comments from
the locals Community EK says if you say
fascist three times Ron DeSantis appears
and gives you a speech about Freedom so
scary
that's good that's good talway says
Saturday Night Live is showing its 50
years of age it's just like your grandpa
jokes were that jokes were funny at 20
oh sorry jokes that were funny at 20
just make your eyes roll now yeah
Saturday Night Live I watched a few of
the other Clips I mean it's absolutely
terrible uh and again there were there
were moments in Chappelle's uh monologue
that I I didn't love I think he said
some things that probably should have
been cleaned up a little bit or whatever
but better late than never when it comes
to getting to the party so what makes
Dave Chappelle a Democrat I mean this is
this is the same thing that I'm doing
with with Bill Maher all the time and
and some of these other people it's like
I don't know what makes you a Democrat
other than you only know yourself as a
Democrat but if you like what
Chappelle's saying there is holy [ __ ]
here's somebody saying all of the stuff
that I've wanted to say for a long time
that actually is true and he was doing
it on stage in front of the world I
don't know maybe you should have
supported that guy then maybe that guy's
not the most evil person in the world
and some of the other stuff that Jordan
Peterson said Buttercup says Dems would
vote for for a potato if they were told
to look I think that we have to come to
that conclusion at some level whether
it's a potato or it's veteran like a
certain amount of people in this country
are going to vote Democrat no matter
what that could be bad branding on the
Republicans it could be bad education
because people don't know what has freed
them and what our history is and what
what Independence means or any of those
things but we have to learn how to fight
better I think and again that's why I
keep bringing everything back to Florida
because it's happening somewhere so when
it's happening in a place and it's good
and it's just and as despite what Anna
Navarro says nobody's questioning the
election results and people are thrilled
to be here and hundreds of thousands of
people have come here while literally
half a million people fled New York in
the last couple years and almost 400 000
people I think have now left California
in the last two years it's like that
model is right and maybe it can only be
done at the state level
right maybe the best thing would be that
it does you really just shouldn't care
that much what a governor in another
state is doing you should care to some
degree about their senators and their
Congress people because they're voting
on giant spending packages and can vote
you into war and everything else but at
the end of the day
as for me as a Floridian does it matter
that much whether Kerry lake is going to
win in Arizona or not do I think she's
way better than Katie hubs and cares
about American more and all that stuff
yes but at the end of the day she's the
executive of Arizona and how much does
that affect my life actually pretty much
zero I want us to be the United States
of America but we got to get back to
figuring out what unites us uh all right
I think this was a I think this was a
solid show from DC I'm going to sit down
with uh Congressman Jim Jordan in just a
few minutes and then we'll be posting
that this week as I said we've got Ted
Cruz we've got Marcia Blackburn we've
got Byron Donald's we've got Rand Paul
we're going to try to add in a couple
other people I think tomorrow afternoon
maybe we'll wander around the mall so uh
maybe we'll see some of you guys out
there go to The Monuments and that sort
of stuff as always if you have not
subscribed at rumble.com Reuben report
and join us uh during the show you can
chat live at reubenaportalocals.com my
full interview with Michael schurmer is
up my full interview with JP Sears is up
I've been doing a lot of talking I
really need some water goodbye but our
significant climate investment will vote
help Turbo Charge the emerge the energy
the excuse me turbocharged the emerging
Global clean energy clean energy economy
I was reading their quote sorry